um hello everyone uh welcome to this
journey into time series analysis um
with TS bootstrap and this presentation
enals the cap capabilities of this
Library um it's a Cutting Edge python
library that transforms the way we
approach bootstrapping for time series
data we'll explore the various
Innovative features that this Library
offers and what makes it stand out in
the realm of data
science
the agenda uh will be something like
this we'll start with um explaining um
what time series is the specific
challenges of Time series why
traditional bootstrapping methods don't
work well for time series data then I'll
overview some key techniques implemented
in TS bootstrap like Markov bootstrap
residual bootstrap a block bootstrap
I'll demo the library functionality
quickly and then we'll finish with take
a for using TS bootstrap in your own
work so let's start with a simple
analysis right um what is time series
it's um a sequence of data points
collected over time intervals
representing change of variables so
essentially you have a two columns one
is your time stamp um two is some
variable um analyzing time series poses
unique
challenges um namely autocorrelation
where data points are correlated with
their past values this complicates
traditional methods of analysis
non-stationarity where statistical
properties change over time this could
be mean variance curtosis what have you
uh this adds another layer of
complexity analyzing and addressing
these challenges is crucial for accurate
forecasting and understanding um
underlying patterns and which is why
time series analysis is usually a
separate Topic in and of itself than
traditional IID data
analysis well the library is called TS
bootstrap so it stands to reason we
should start with understanding what
bootstrapping is I'm sure everyone here
already knows but just as a quick
refresher bootstrapping refers to
resampling your data set with
replacement to a oximate the unknown
sampling distribution it's commonly used
for obtaining confidence intervals for
model validation for hypothesis testing
um classical bootstrap assumes IID data
uh which um as I explained earlier is
ineffective for time
data so uh assume you have a Time series
where the uh the time stamps they go
from 1 through um 16 um oh Pardon Me 1
through 15 it's a 15 unit long time
series um this slide uh visually
represents or demonstrates um what
regular I bootstrapping looks like so
here I have three draws um if you look
at the very first row uh where I've
highlighted with red arrows um the
timestamp or the index five repeats
three times the index one repeats twice
similar things happen in the other two
draws also the the reason for this um is
to highlight that
bootstrapping um the way traditionally
the term bootstrapping is used it refers
to resampling with
replacement uh replacement being the key
term oh there was the next slide there
we
go why does classical bootstrapping fail
well well the key issue is that
classical bootstrapping it disrupts the
temporal ordering of observations in
Time series data so you end up
destroying the inherent autocorrelation
structure you start treating your data
falsely as IID which breaks all
statistical assumptions that are
required for validity the arrow of time
really goes in One Direction so you
can't as you can intuitively think about
it you can't just jumble up those
indices or those time stamps ad hoc as
you would be able to do for classical or
traditional
bootstrapping this Library implements
several bootstrapping methods um in this
presentation I will focus on two of
these uh block bootstrap and residual
bootstrap uh block bootstrap is the most
common uh bootstrapping method used for
time series analysis um so we'll spend
some time going over it uh whereas
residual
bootstrap um is along with say other
methods such as Mark of bootstrapping
Civ
bootstrapping um which are um included
in this Library um are a little more
advanced uh technique um residual
bootstrapping is a little more advanced
technique but it gives you um
significant more
flexibility um depending on the kind of
Time series data you're dealing with um
so blog bootstrapping
um as you can see on the left side here
we resample blocks of consecutive
observations rather than individual
points so you Chunk Up indices together
and then you um resample with
replacement what you end up doing is you
end up maintaining shortterm
chronological Integrity the key as you
can then imagine is selecting the
appropriate block length uh to trade off
bias and
variance um this this method uh this
Library gives you other methods like
residual boot straing where instead of
um a resampling the original time points
you fit a model to it um you get the
residuals and then you resample those
residuals uh not shown here but included
in the library are Mark of bootstrapping
SE bootstrapping Mark of bootstrapping
assumes that the residuals they follow a
markof process with limited memory
so you take your original time series
data could be univariate could be
multivariate you fit a model of your
choice could be something simple as AR
Rema could be a really fancy deep
learning model you get
residuals um and if your assumption is
that the residuals follow a mark of
process with some limited memory uh then
markco bootstrapping would perhaps be
the right choice for um you know your
case here we resample the residuals
rather than the original series like I
mentioned Which Way in in which way we
end up preserving both the marginal
distribution and the short run
Dynamics another method uh that's
presented in the library is Civ
bootstrapping which is a semi-
parametric approach similar to residual
and Markov where you capture long-term
temporal dependencies by fitting an AR
Model Auto regressive model to the time
series before resampling the
residuals now with this sort of high
level um overview out of the way we can
spend some time really understanding
what block bootstrapping is like I
briefly mentioned this is the most
popular type of bootstrapping the tldr
is um Shunk up your time series data
into blocks and then resample the blocks
um this Library allows you to uh
significant flexibility in the way you
can select the block length you can the
user can provide a fixed block length or
he or she can provide a distribution
from which to draw the block length um
you have flexibility in how to overlap
two blocks uh we're going to look at
that you have flexibility um to assign
different weights to different points in
each block you can say the center of the
block is much more important than the
edges so you can have a tapering
function or you can say the start of the
block is much more important than the
end um so that comes later that's just a
sort of a Prelude um blog bootstrapping
um as you can see here is instead of
fiddling with individual points we
Shuffle whole blocks of data while
keeping their order and auto correlation
structure intact as much as possible
there are four main types of blog
resampling strategies in literature and
also implemented in this Library uh
moving blog bootstrapping stationary
blog boot strapping circular block boot
strapping and non-overlapping block boot
strapping what makes block bootstrapping
stand out from classical bootstrap is
its ability to preserve time
dependencies at least in the shortterm
uh it is the go-to for many people for
time series data uh plus it's a cinch to
compute and it's lightning fast um so in
short block bootstrapping is a building
block for more Advanced bootstrapping
Techniques and it helps up helps us make
sense of Time series data um with more
accurate and valid
inferences so that's a lot of talk let's
look at something
visual again uh recall that um my time
series indices are 1 through
15 and I have three draws uh you'll
recall from a previous slide that um we
drew individual points but here like I
mentioned we draw blocks before drawing
blocks the first step would be to
actually create those
blocks um so here I've specified a block
length of three um moving block
bootstrapping allows you to start from
anywhere in your um time series data and
you still resample with replacement so
in um draw one you'll see blocks um
consisting of indices one to three are
repeated this is similar to the
repetition um I showed earlier similarly
in draw two blocks seven through n are
repeated um
moving block bootstrapping is used for
time series data where blocks are
resampled to maintain dependency
structure uh within the blocks it's
specifically useful when data has
dependencies that need to be preserved
and I would not recommend this when the
data does not have any significant
dependencies circular block boot
strapping um so uh if you notice the
last slide carefully you'll see that we
didn't actually uh we didn't ever go
back from index 15 to index one however
circular block bootstrapping allows one
to do that this this method of block
bootstrapping it treats the data as if
it is circular I.E the end of the data
is next to the beginning of the data
it's useful when your data is cyclical
or
seasonal um and of course it's not
recommended when the data does not have
a cyclical or seasonal component so here
arrows I've tried to point out those
specific blocks uh so 15 to two when
draw two you start at index 15 and then
you Loop all the way around to one and
two uh while keeping the block size of
three um constant same thing in draw
three we start at 14 we go to 15 and
then we go to one the second we reach
the block size of three
um um you know we stop um another thing
to note is right here if you notice uh
block six and eight and block seven and
N there is
overlap um by default the way circular
block bootstrapping moving block
bootstrapping are defined in literature
there is an overlap uh however I allow
the user in the library to set what this
overlap needs to be to to hard Cod a
value or to set a Min value or max value
if they don't want any overlap they can
also do
that stationary plog bootstrapping
randomly resamples blocks of data with
block lens that follow a geometric
distribution um so the so the idea here
is that the block length isn't constant
but it's drawn from a distribution and
that distribution is a geometric
distribution it's useful for time series
um where the degree of dependency needs
to be preserved and it doesn't require
strict stationarity of the underlying
process it's not recommended when the
data has strong seasonality or Trend
which this weak dependence assumption
Again by these yellow arrows I've
pointed out those blocks uh where block
lens are greater than the
um oh um you know what ignore the the
third draw because that's an error uh
just if you could focus on the the
errors in the first two draws um I'd
given a block length of um three um as
the that is a parameter of the geometric
distribution and in this draw uh one of
the block lens is a block of just a
singular value number three this is
index 5 um so this is um easily allowed
um or or can easily be achieved in this
Library I have extended this
functionality where the user uh is not
restricted to drawing just from a GE
distribution if you know uh or if you
learn that your data the blocks um there
is a um um they're drawn from some other
distribution um you can pick any of the
ones allowed by scipi um so that's
easily doable using this
library and finally non-overlapping
block bootstrapping as the name um
clearly implies here we resample blocks
of data without overlap it's useful
specifically when your data has
dependencies that need to be reserved
and when overfitting specifically is a
concern if the data does not have
significant
dependencies or when the introduction of
bias due to non-overlap selection is a
concern then perhaps non-overlapping
block bootstrapping is not the best for
you
um yeah if you if you notice closely
there is literally uh no overlap um in
any of the blocks however there is still
repetition so for instance blocks 1 2 3
1 2 3 789 789 are repeated and uh in in
all these draws you keep on drawing
blocks until the length of the the new
time series equals the length of the
original time
series this is um my favorite okay so
here now that we've um covered block
bootstrapping we're going to move on to
the other uh sort of building block
bootstrapping me um building
bootstrapping method that's allowed by
this Library called residual
bootstrapping and I wanted to again
demonstrate visually uh when and why uh
this method would be useful so um the
blue line is um your original time
series uh this is yals to X plot um you
go from index one through
15 um now let's say um if I follow
either IID bootstrapping or blot
bootstrapping um in this example I
followed
um block boot strapping where in my
first draw I draw samples one two and
three that's my first
block um oh pardon me uh we're looking
at the the y axis so we draw samples uh
9 10 and
11 this is our very first
block second draw we draw 7 8 and n and
so on I'm following the red curve here
um and then we basically stitch them
together in the order in which they're
drawn so this is block boot wrapping
this is um you know moving block boot
wrapping um and then we have two similar
draws the idea here is what I'm trying
to demonstrate is let's say if you have
um even a simple linear Trend um in your
time T data and you and you go ahead
with moving block boot strapping the
kind of results you'll get after
stitching those indices together the fin
fin time series will probably not
resemble the original time series um uh
you know in several properties here for
instance um if you look at the yellow
one um and if you were to fit a you know
best fit line it'll be a horizontal line
which means you've lost the trend
completely so this is where we come to
the realm of um parametric or semi-
parametric bootstrapping method
specifically in this presentation um I
have demonstrated residual bootstrapping
so this is one of the several
model-based approaches that are um
available in this
Library um it is a very popular
modelbased approach uh what you do is um
you first fit a model to the data and
then you bootstrap the residuals in TS
bootstrap I've provided
um several um statistical models
starting with araa ar uh and some
volatility based models also to deal
with financial data um this particular
method can be advantageous as it allows
the bootstrap method to take into
account the structure of the model um so
fit a model of your choice to the
original data get the residuals resample
the residuals add them back to the fit
and that's in new time series um the the
difference between the resampled data
here and here is I'm sure you can see
visually quite striking you maintain the
trend it allows you this uh method
allows you to handle changing
distributions drift uh since residual
bootstrapping is is um based on a fitted
model it can better handle situations
where the data distribution changes over
time it is better for complex
distributions um as the dependent
structure is captured by the model
rather than by the blocks it is less
sensitive to block size um because it
does not require choosing a block size
making it just less sensitive or really
not at all sensitive to this parameter
it can be more efficient depending on
the model used residual bootstrapping
can more computationally can be more
computationally efficient than block
bootstrapping especially for larger data
sets with that you know all of that
introduction out of the way it was it
was very important to cover the basics
because these are the functionalities
that TS bootstrap
offers it is an open-source property
tested not just unit tested we use
hypothesis for property testing it has
85% coverage currently and I plan to
increase it to 90 by the end of the
month it is extremely flexible it is
very well documented and it's very easy
to use I provide um both basic plog
bootstrapping and advanced bootstrapping
methods such as residual which we you
know which we saw visually SI
bootstrapping Mark of bootstrapping uh
distribution Mo bootstrapping statistic
preserving bootstrapping um I encourage
you to um actually go um to the GitHub
page uh or the PIP page and look at the
documentation where I've described these
methods in some detail and when to use
them and when not to use them
um what I've also been able to do
because the code is so modular is for
the advanced methods you can apply them
as is to your time series or you can
combine them with the block
bootstrapping methods so for instance
the residual bootstrapping method that
we saw earlier you can fit a model to
your original time series get the
residuals and instead of ad hoc um
resampling the residuals assuming their
IID you can can then bring in Block
bootstrapping sh them into blocks
bootstrap them resample them add them
back to the fitted uh values and now you
have your new time
series um like I mentioned it's uh the
table of contents the readme file is
quite well
documented um I I um tell you which file
um or which module which class each
method is implemented in um and there
are examples how to use them
it is um extremely modular um the code
is structured into District modules for
ease of Maintenance and extension it is
Enterprise great code it has a very
detailed readme file uh contributing
guidelines usage examples it follows dry
and solid principles for efficient code
management it has excellent CD it is
community focused uh and includes a
couple of conduct and contributing
guidelines to Foster Community
involvement we already have some open
issues um it has a simplified setup and
a setup process using a setup script um
and we're working to integrate TS
bootstrap into SK time because of the
way it's coded it's uh actually very
easy I'm in contact with the devs of SK
time to integrate bootstrapping TS
bootstrap specifically into skap time
what this would allow you um is the
ability for excellent uncertainty
quantification um so if you have your
original time series a blackbox model
that forecasts either one step ahead or
end steps ahead but you're not sure what
the um error bars there should there
could be uh you can take your original
time series create multiple copies using
TS bootstrap feed it to the same model
get multiple outputs and now you have a
distribution SK time already has a
endtoend pipeline set up um for
everything except the bootstrapping part
um and this the Synergy is just
fantastic how to use it it's like I
mentioned it's extremely easy um I
followed the config Paradigm um to keep
code very neat you literally do Pit
install TS bootstrap uh in this example
I've demonstrated how to use moving
block bootstrap and then you import the
config
you create an instance by mentioning the
block length and the number of
bootstraps you want um and then you have
your
generator where you um you can either
specify if you want to return the
indices in addition to actual um value
values for the variables or not uh this
was inspired by the way cross validation
and done as in SK learn where they
follow the generator Paradigm um
in the the visual examples where I
showed I showed you distinct blocks what
What's Happening Here is those blocks
are just stitched together in the order
in which they are drawn so you have if
the block length is three you have 9 10
11 7 8 9
567 um like I mentioned uh reputation is
okay block length is preserved and so on
and then you have three six distinct
draws finally uh here's my contact
information uh please reach out either
on LinkedIn or via email um if you have
um any open any suggestions concerns uh
feature requests uh if you find buds um
definitely open an issue uh ping me and
um yeah I think we ended at almost 25
minutes leaving five minutes for uh
Q&A
um yeah any question questions I'm going
to look at
[Music]
the I think there's a question in the
Q&A and there might be a question in
chat as well let's do the Q&A I'm sorry
Aris I couldn't quite understand you
there I'm sorry I think we have one
question in the Q&A I'll bring it up on
screen okay you're right you're right
I'm seeing it right now there you
go
ah uh so a um sorry if I'm butchering
that name uh um residual bootstrapping
um doesn't actually um by default
doesn't actually um use a distribution
function um it the block length I'm
guessing you're referring to the block
length is fixed it's user specified um
so you can specify what block length um
and and yeah that's the um if you
combine residual bootstrapping and block
bootstrapping that's the block length
right there uh or the other way I can
interpret this question is um you don't
combine block bootstrapping with
residual bootstrapping um and then you
assume that when you do IID resampling
of your um residuals you're assuming
they follow a normal distribution as
with IIT data so I'm not sure if that
answered it I I answered it from two
perspectives
any other
questions I think there was a quick one
in chat you're right are there occasions
when you might want to use this property
and use Ma or ar mod absolutely
absolutely yeah um I I provide um very
convenient U wrappers around AR ma um
Arma ARA CA and some volatility based
models um so the choice of which model
to use is really up to the user um as a
data scientist um mle um you know time
series specialist um you do some
analysis on your time series or or you
get with domain experts and you figure
out what would be the best model to
capture the underlying properties of
your time series data um and then you go
from there so absolutely intution is
right there are times when Ma would be a
better fit than AR